this began as a riff for this American
life what was the process of getting it
there um well actually it started
because I wanted to make it into a film
so I had started writing the screenplay
and always imagined it as a film but
nobody wanted to let me make it in this
particular version and I did this
American Life because the producer one
of the producers there Neal drumming
came up to me and said so what stories
is our Hollywood not letting you tell
give this to me I want to bring them to
this American Life and so I said funny
you should ask there's a story about my
grandmother and you know that's how it
started so you know of course so we
wrote I wrote and then narrated it for
this American Life it took about a month
and a half and then after it aired
within 48 hours I got all these calls
from producers saying they now wanted to
make it into a film now you find out
okay and so so what was the process like
as they all came knocking at your door
who was bidding who was offering who was
promising what well there were like
different companies of different sizes
you know who wanted to make the film and
like so basically I'll say but before I
did this American Life I pitched a bunch
of production companies and people kept
saying is this an American film or a
Chinese film and if I said well it's an
American film cuz I'm American and this
is from my perspective but you know I do
want to cast it 100% Chinese Chinese
American because that's what reflects my
family and the people in China would
actually speak Chinese so it'd be
subtitled you know you could tell about
what that was the word subtitles right
yeah subtitles they were like yeah no
this is a foreign film usually go
picture did you know China like a
Chinese company and but then I would go
pitch it to a Chinese company and they
would say it's a great concept but if
it's a Chinese film the main character
cannot be Billie her perspective is to
American and Chinese audiences are not
gonna resonate so you have to create a
Chinese character who's rooted in like
these Chinese values and maybe Billie
can be a friend
and so an either version it was not the
story that I wanted to tell this was
very close because it was about your
family how did you have to take their
feelings and anticipate their reactions
and take that into account well I had my
parents read the script pretty early on
more for practical reasons because as we
were doing translations into Chinese I
don't read or write Chinese so I needed
them to read it to tell me if it seemed
or that was your story anyway right yeah
and I also wanted to make sure I was
being respectful so I had them read the
script and we went back and forth on
more on like translation stuff and so
yeah I think that with my parents were
the only ones who read the script no one
else had but I cast my great aunt in the
movie to play herself like little 9 I is
my real little 9 I and Ellen is her real
dog but the dog has an agent I gather
from oh now she does yeah yeah now she's
like sag and everything so screen
animals go yeah but it works for
multiple reasons casting my great aunt
one is that Ellen won't sing for anybody
else and I always knew I had to the cast
Ellen because I don't know any other
singing dogs and and if I had cast like
an actor to play a little my night there
would they wouldn't Ellen wouldn't sing
for that anyone else but it also was
great because it allowed me throughout
the process to check in with her to make
sure that it felt authentic what about
the other members of your family most of
them haven't seen it yet my great-aunt
just saw it on Monday in New York she
came to the premiere in New York and she
cried a lot in a good way but but it was
very emotional for her because she
thought she was gonna ruin my movie she
kept saying like I'm a normal person my
fat face is gonna ruin your movie don't
cast me so it was wonderful for her to
see it with an audience and everybody
coming up to her after and say like you
were so great can I take a selfie with
you so that was really great yeah that's
it no one else has seen it
grandmother has not seen it but that'll
be coming soon
I don't know mmm it's a it's a good
question so she still does not know she
has not seen the movie and we can't show
her because that means and she'll
because then she would know but so now
the whole world is keeping your secret
yeah it's complicated my mother this
morning we talked this morning and she
was like so I've been thinking maybe
it's time to tell your grandmother like
now I mean really she's like well you
know you're in the New York Times the
whole world's gonna know soon I mean the
whole world was you know we were like in
London with the movie and we got a
Chinese distributor so it's gonna come
out in China and the Chinese title of
the movie is different than the English
what is it it's don't tell her I didn't
come up with that my mother did as far
as the casting goes who did you start
with apart from your own great an
Aquafina was the first person we cast
because we couldn't greenlight the
project if we didn't have somebody
playing Billy and I back when you know
my producer bought up her name I only
knew of her from her rap videos and so
your first thought was was you you think
that the woman from Queens who did my
vag should play me in a dramatic was
literally what I said to my producer was
like let's talk what kind of movie do
you see I thought that we agreed this
was not gonna be that kind of movie um
but yeah so she said you should just
meet with her cuz she read the script
and she really liked it and you know you
never know and so we met and Aquafina
aka Norrell um was raised by her own
Chinese grandmother oh and it was very
very close with her grandma fina
and and she just brought you know she
sent in a self taped audition and I
watched it and she brought like so you
could see that that she brought all of
her personal experiences and she has
this great gift of being able to
actually translate that onto screen you
know I thought she has this really great
face where she's both blank but also
full of expression at the same time and
it just carry a lot of the tension and
the conflict that I was looking for and
as far as the logistics of shooting in
China and in New York what were the
difficulties that were presented to you
uh well like we you know anything goes
in China which is both good and bad
right like everyone works really hard
people are used to seven-day weeks and
people are like you know used to just
kind of being owned by the production
for the duration of the production and
there's like a real hierarchy that kind
of mimics like the the old like Emperor
system like people didn't call me by my
name they just call me director and they
feel like director do you want this do
you want this do you want that and then
you know I came back to America nobody
called me director uh-huh and I would be
like can I get this thing they're like
let's check with the unions first like
okay right so yeah it's just very very
different but but both great in
different ways you know I mean I think
in China it was just such like an
extension of my family and like the film
and the process was an extension of my
family where it was just like chaos all
the time but you know I look at
organized chaos what do you want people
to take away from this film I guess I
want people to I think a lot of people
come into the film with an idea of like
a very strong perspective on the lie and
I don't I'm not necessarily trying to
change people's mind at all because like
I said I don't even know what's right or
wrong but I just hope that people come
out of it with a little bit of
compassion a little bit more
understanding for the other side
a recognition that maybe it's not about
finding the answers maybe there is no
right or wrong and it's not our job to
make this judgement because you know
we're living in such polarizing times
and I've had so many people say that you
know that they're divided from their
family because they have a different
perspective and they're not even
immigrants they're not from another
country they're just like you know from
Texas but live in New York City and
those are very different cultures right
and so I think I just want people to
look at this and look at the see the
film and think about how we can learn to
disagree with the ones we love but
maintain a sense a you know sense of
respect and just because life is short
and I think so many people end up having
regrets over these differences dividing
them and their loved ones we thank you
for your work Lou Lou Wong thanks for
being here